the following is a conversation with
magnus carlsen the number one ranked
chess player in the world and widely
considered to be one of if not the
greatest chess player of all time
the camera magnus died 20 minutes into
the conversation most folks still just
listen to the audio through a podcast
player anyway
but if you're watching this
on youtube or spotify we did our best to
still make it interesting by adding
relevant image overlays
i messed things up sometimes like in
this case
but i'm always working hard to improve
i hope you understand
thank you for your patience and support
along the way
i love you all
this is the lex friedman podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's magnus carlsen
you're considered by many to be one of
the greatest if not the greatest chess
players of all time but you're also one
of the best fantasy football aka soccer
competitors in the world plus recently
picking up poker and
competing at a world-class level so
before chess let's talk football and
greatness
you're a real madrid fan
so let me ask you the ridiculous big
question who do you think is the
greatest football
aka soccer player of all time can you
make the case for messi can you make the
case for cristiano ronaldo
pele maradona does something anybody
jump to mind
i think it's pretty hard to make a case
for
anybody else
than messi for his uh for his all-around
game
and uh
frankly like my
real madrid fandom sort of
uh predates the ronaldo
era era uh this the second ronaldo not
not not the first one so i always liked
ronaldo but i always kind of thought
that
messi was
was better
and
i went to quite a number of madrid games
and they've always been super helpful to
me down there the only thing is that
like they asked me
they were gonna do an interview and they
were gonna ask me who my favorite player
was and
um
i said somebody else i think i said isko
at that point and i was like okay take
two now you say ronaldo
so for them it was um it was very
important but it wasn't wasn't that huge
too um
to me so messy over maradona
yeah but it's i think
just like with chess it's hard to
compare eras
obviously the improvements in football
have been like
in in technique and such have been even
greater than they have been in in in
just but it's um
it's always um it's always a weird weird
discussion uh to have but just as a fan
what do you
think is
beautiful about the game what defines
greatness is it
you know with messi
one he's really good at finishing
two very good at assists
like three there's just magic it's just
beautiful to see the play so it's not
just about the finishing there's some
it's like marduna's hand of god there's
some
creativity
on the pitch is is that important or is
it very important to get the world cups
and the big championships and that kind
of stuff i think the world cup is pretty
pretty overrated seeing us um as it's uh
such a small sample size so
uh
uh it sort of annoys me always when you
know titles are always um
always appreciated so much
even though
that particular title can be
can be a lot of a lot of
luck or at least some
at least some luck
so i do appreciate um
statistics a bit and all the statistics
say that mess is
the best finisher of all time which i
think helps a lot
and then there's the intangibles as well
the flip side of that is the small
sample size
is what
really
creates the magic
it's so it's just like the olympics
you you basically train your whole life
for this you live your whole life for
this and it's a rare moment one mistake
and it's all over
that's
for some reason a lot of people
either break under that pressure or rise
up under that pressure you don't you
don't admire the magic of that no i i do
i just think that like rising and
to the pressure and breaking on the
under the pressure is often a really
oversimplified
like
uh taken on what's um on what's
happening we're yeah we do romanticize
the game yeah well let me ask you
another ridiculous question another
you're also a fan of basketball
yes
let me ask the goat question do you i
you know i'm biased because uh i went to
high school in chicago
uh you know chicago bulls during the the
michael jordan era uh let me ask the the
jordan versus lebron james question
let's let's continue on this threat of
greatness which one do you pick or
somebody else
so i'll give you a completely different
answer
um
depending on my mood and depending who
on whom i talk to i pick one of one of
the two and then i tried to argue the
quantum mechanical thing well can you
what
again what
what would uh if you were to argue for
either one
statistically i think lebron james is
going to surpass jordan yeah no doubt
and so
again there's a
debate between
unquantifiable greatness no that i mean
that's the whole that's the whole debate
yes so it's well it's quantifiable
versus unquantifiable yeah what's more
important and you're depending on mood
yeah all over the place
but what do you lean in general with
these f with these folks with with
soccer with anything in life
towards the unquantifiable more no
definitely towards the quantifiable so
when you're unsure lean towards the
numbers yeah but see like it's later
generations
there's something that's what people say
about maradona is you know he took uh
arguably somewhat mediocre team
to a world cup
so there's that also uplifting nature of
the player to be able to rise up the
whole it is a team sport so are you
gonna like are you gonna punish um
messi for
taking a mediocre argentine squad to to
the to the final in 2014 and punish him
because they lost to
a great team very narrowly after they
missed
he set up like a great chance for iguain
in the first half which he
um which he fluffed and then yeah
eventually they lost the game
yeah they they do criticize cristiano
ronaldo messi for being on really strong
squads in terms of the club
teams and saying yeah okay it's easy
when you have like ronaldinho or whoever
on your team
it would be very interesting just uh if
the league could make a
decision
yeah just random random allocation yeah
um
and just every single game just keep
relocating or maybe once a season um or
every season you get random but let's
say every
every player
um
if let's say they sign a five-year
contract for a team like one of them
you're going to get randomly allocated
to
to let's say a bottom half team
i bet you there's going to be so much
corruption around that could be not
obviously it wouldn't
ever happen or or work but i think it's
if you never know first thing to think
about so on chess
let's uh zoom out
if you break down your approach to chess
when you're at your best
uh what
what do you think um
what do you think contributes to that
approach is it memory recall specific
lines and positions is it intuition how
much of it is intuition how much of it
is pure calculation how much of it is
messing with the strategy of the
opponent so the game theory aspect
in terms of what contributes to the
highest level of play that um that you
do
i think
the answer
differs a little bit now from what it
did
eight years ago
for instance like i've i feel like i've
had like two peaks in in my career in
2014
uh well 2013 2014 and also in 2019 and
in those
years i i was very different
um
in terms of um
of my strength
strengths as specifically in 2019 i
benefited a lot from
opening preparation
uh while in 2013 2014 i mostly tried to
avoid my
uh opponent's
preparation rather than that being a um
being a strength
so
i'm mentioning that also because it's
something something you didn't um
didn't mention i think like my
intuitive understanding of chess has
over those years
always been a little bit
better than the others even though it
has
evolved as well um
certainly there are there are things
that i understand now that i didn't
understand
back then but that's not only for me
that's for
for others as well
i was younger back then so i played with
more energy which meant that i could
play better in long drawn out
games
which was also a necessity for me
because i didn't i couldn't
couldn't beat people in the
in the openings um
but
in terms of calculation that's always
been a weird issue for
me like i've always been really really
um
bad at solving exercises in chess like
that's been
like a blind spot for me first of all i
found it hard to
concentrate on them um
and to look
uh to look deep enough so this is like a
puzzle a position yeah me in x i mean
one thing is made but
find the best move that's generally the
exercise like find the best move find
the best line
you just don't connect with it usually
like you have to to look look deep and
then when i get these lines during
the game i've
very often find
the
the right solution even though
um
even though i'm it's not still
the best part of my game
to to calculate very
very deeply but it doesn't feel like
calculation you're saying
in terms of no it does sometimes but
for me it's more like i'm at the board
trying to find trying to find the
solution and i understand like the
training
at home is like trying a little bit to
to replicate that like you give somebody
half an hour um in a position like in
this
instance you might have thought for half
an hour if you play the game but i just
i just cannot do it one thing i know
that i am good at though
is
calculating
short lines
because i calculate them them well i'm
good at seeing
little details and i'm also
much better than than most at uh
evaluating
which i think is something that sets me
sets me uh apart from from others so
evaluating specific position
if i
if i make this move and the position
changes in this way
is this the step in the right direction
like in a big picture way yeah like you
calculate a few moves ahead and then you
evaluate because a lot a lot of time
a lot of the times you cannot
um the branches become so big that you
cannot calculate everything so you have
a fog yeah so you have to you have to
make evaluations based on you know
based based mostly on knowledge and and
intuition and somehow i seem to do that
uh pretty well when you say you're good
at short lines what's that what's what's
short
that's usually like lines of um
two to four moves each okay so that
that's directly applicable to even
faster games like blitz chess and so on
yeah um blitz is
a lot about
calculating force lines
so those
you can see pretty clearly that the
players who struggle at blitz who are
great at classical are those who rely on
a deep calculating ability because you
simply ha don't have time for for that
templates you have to calculate quickly
and rely a lot on iteration can you try
to i know it's really difficult can you
try to
talk through what's actually being
visualized in your head
is there
is there a visual component yeah no i
just visualized the board i mean the
board isn't as in as in my head
two-dimensional my interpretation is
that it's it is too uh two-dimensional
like what color is is is it brown tinted
is it black is it
uh like what's the theme is it a big
bore small board
are the
uh what do the pawns look
like or is it more in the space of
concepts
like uh
yeah
there are there aren't a lot of colors
it's it's mostly
[Laughter]
so what is it queen's gambit on the
ceiling whatever
to imagine it what about when you do the
branching when you have multiple boards
and so on what how does that look are
you no there's only one at a time so
like position in time one position at a
time so then i go back
and and that's what when when people
play
or at least that's what i do when i play
blindfold chess against several people
then it's just always one border at a
time and
the rest are stored away somewhere but
how do you store them away so like you
went down one branch you're like all
right that's i got that
i understand that that's there's some
good there there's some bad there now
let me go down another branch like how
do you store away the information you
just put on a shelf kind of
i i try and store it away sometimes i
have to sort of repeat it because i
forget
and it does happen frequently in games
that
um
you're thinking for
especially if you're thinking for long
let's say half an hour or even more than
that that you play a move and then your
opponent plays a move then you play a
move and they play a move again and you
realize oh
i actually calculated that i just forgot
about it
um so that's obviously what happens when
you store the information and you cannot
retrieve it when you think about a move
for 20 30 minutes
like how do you break that down
what can you describe what
like what's the algorithm here that
takes 30 minutes to run
30 minutes is uh
at least for me it's usually a waste um
30 minutes
usually means that i don't know what to
do
and i'm trying i'm just running into the
wall over here yeah i'm trying to find
something that isn't there i think
um 10 to 15 minutes things in
complicated positions can be really
really
uh helpful then you can
spend your time pretty
um efficiently um just
it just means that the branches are
getting getting wider so there's a lot
to
um to run through um both in terms of
calculation and a lot you have to
evaluate as well and then based on based
on that 10 to 15 minutes think you you
have a pretty good idea uh what to
what to do i mean it's it's very rare
that i would think for half an hour and
i would have a eureka moment
during the game like if i haven't seen
it in 10 minutes i'm probably not going
to see it at all you're going to
different branches yeah and like after
15 minutes it's like
mainly to the middle game because when
you get to the end game it's
usually brute force calculation that
makes you spend so much time so middle
game is
normally it's it's it's a complicated
mix of brute force calculation and and
uh and um
by creativity and evaluation so end game
it's it's it's more it's it's easier in
that sense well
you're good at
every aspect of chess but you're also
your end game is legendary it baffles
experts so uh can you linger on that
then try to explain what the heck is
going on there like if you look at game
six of the previous world championship
uh the longest game
ever
played in chess
it was uh
i think
uh his queen versus your rook knight in
two pawns yeah there's so many options
there it's such an interesting little
little dance and it's kind of not
obvious that it wouldn't be a draw so
how do you escape
the it not being a draw and you win that
match
no i knew um that for most of the time
it was a theoretical draw since um
chess with seven or less pieces on the
board is solved so you can like people
who watching online they can just check
it they can check and
they can check a so-called table base
and they it just gonna spit out when for
white win for black or a draw so
and and also i i knew that i knew that
didn't know that
position specifically but i knew that it
had to be a draw so for me it was
about
staying alert
first of all
trying to look for
the best way to put my pieces
uh but but
yeah those end games are a bit
they're a bit unusual they don't happen
too often so what i'm usually
good at is i'm using my my strengths
that i also use in
in middle games is that i
evaluate well and i calculate short
variations
quite uh even for the end game short
variations matter yes it does matter in
some simpler end games yeah but also
like
there are
these theoretical end games with very
few pieces like rook knights and two
pawns versus queens but a lot of end
games are simply defined by the queens
being exchanged
and there are a lot of other pieces left
and then
it's usually not brute force it's
usually
more of understanding and evaluation and
then then i can use my my strengths um
very well
why are you so damn good at the end game
isn't there a lot of moves
from
when the end game starts to when the end
game finishes and you have a few pieces
you have to figure out it's like a
sequence of little games that happens
right like little pattern like how how
does it being able to evaluate a single
position lead you to
evaluate a long sequence of positions
that eventually lead to a checkmate well
i think if you evaluate well at the
start you know what plans to go for and
then
usually the play from there is
is often pretty simple
let's say you understand
how
to
arrange your pieces and
often also how to arrange your pawns
early in the end game
then
that makes
all all the
all the difference and
after that is like what we call
technique
of very often uh that it's
technique basically just
means that
the moves are simple and uh
these are moves that you know
a lot of players could
could make not only
not only the very strongest ones these
are moves that are kind of
understood and unknown so with the
evaluation you're just constantly
improving a little bit and that just
leads to suffocating the position and
then eventually to the wind as long as
you're doing the evaluation well
one step at a time to some extent
also yeah as i said like if you evaluate
it better and thus accumulated some
some small advantages then you can you
can often make your
your your life pretty easy uh towards
the end of the end game so you said in
uh 2019 sort of the second phase of why
you're so damn good
you uh you did a lot of opening
preparation
what's the goal
for you
of uh the opening game of chess is it to
throw the opponent off from any prepared
lines
is there something you could put into
words about why you're so damn good at
the openings
again these things have changed
a lot over time
back in kasparov's days for instance
um he very often got
huge advantages from the opening as
as white can explain why
there were
several reasons for for that first of
all he he worked harder he was more
creative and finding ideas he was able
to look places others
didn't
also he had a very strong team of people
who had
specific strengths in
in openings that he could use
so they would come up with ideas and he
would he would integrate those ideas
into yeah and he would also very often
come up with them them himself also
at the start
he had
some of the first computer engines to to
work um for him to
define his ideas to look deeper to
verify as ideas he was better at using
them
than a lot of others
now i feel like the
playing field is a lot more
level there are
both computer engines neural networks
and hybrid engines available to
practically
anybody so it's it's much harder to
find ideas
now that um
that actually like give you an advantage
with what the the white pieces i mean
people don't expect to find those ideas
anymore now it's all about
finding ideas that
are missed by the
engines either they're missed
entirely or they're missed at low depth
and using them to
you know gain some advantage in the
sense that you have more more knowledge
and
you know it's also
good to know that usually
these are not complete bluffs these are
like semi bluffs so that you know that
even if your opponent makes all the
right moves you can still
make a draw
and also at the start of 2019
neural networks had just started to be a
thing in in chess and uh
i'm not entirely sure but there were at
least some players
in
even in the top events you who you could
see did not use them or did not use them
in the right way and then you could gain
a huge advantage because a lot of
positions they were
being evaluated differently by the
neural networks than traditional chess
engines
because they simply think about chess in
a very very
different way so
short answer is these days it's all
about surprising your your opponent and
taking it into position where you have
more more knowledge so is there some
sense in which it's okay to make
suboptimal quote-unquote moves no but
you have to
i mean you you have to
because the best moves have been
analyzed to to death mostly so that's a
kind of when you say sami bluff that's a
kind of sacrifice
you're you're sacrificing the optimal
move the optimal position
so that you can take the opponent i mean
that's the game theoretics yes you take
the opponent into something they didn't
prepare well yeah but you could also
look at it another way
that
regardless like if you turn on
whatever engine you turn on like if you
try to analyze either from
the starting position or the starting
position of some popular opening
like if you um analyze long enough it's
always going to end up in a draw
so
in in that sense you may not be going
for like the objective
the tries that are
objectively the most difficult to draw
against
but you know you are trying to look at
least at the less obvious um paths okay
how much do you use engines do you use
lila
stock fish
in your preparations my team does
personally i try not to use them too
much
on on my own uh because i know that when
i play you can obviously cannot have
help from from engines and
often i feel like often having
imperfect
or knowledge about a position uh or some
engine knowledge can be a lot worse than
than having no knowledge
uh so i try to look at engines as little
as possible
so yeah so your team uses them for
research for a generation of ideas yeah
but you are
uh relying primarily on your human
resources
yeah for sure you can evaluate well
you don't leave yeah i can evaluate as a
human i can know what they find
unpleasant and
and and so on and
it's
very often the case
for me to some extent but
a lot for for others that you arrive in
a position
and your opponent plays a move that you
didn't expect and
you know if you didn't expect it you
know that it's probably not a great move
since it hasn't been expected by by the
engine but
if it's not
if it's not obvious why it's not a good
move
it's usually very very hard to figure it
out
and so then
looking at the engines doesn't
necessarily help because at that point
like you're facing a human you have to
sort of
think as a human i was chatting with the
demonstrable ceo of deepmind a couple
days ago and he asked me to ask you
about what you first felt
when you saw the the play of alpha zero
like interesting ideas any creativity um
did you feel fear that the machine is
taking over did you were you inspired
and you what was going on in your mind
and heart
funny thing about dem is is he he
doesn't play chess at all uh like uh
like an ai
yeah he um plays in a very very
human way
no uh i was
hugely inspired when i i saw the games
at first um
and in terms of
man versus machine i mean that battle
was
was kind of lost for humans even
before i
entered top level chess um so that's
never been an issue uh for me i never
never liked playing against computers
much anyway so so that's completely fine
but it was amazing to see uh how
they quote-unquote thought about chess
and in such a different way and in a way
that you could
mistake for creativity
mistake for cr strong words uh is it
wild to you how many sacrifices it's
willing to make that like sacrifice
pieces and then wait for prolonged
periods of time before doing anything
with that is that
is that weird to you that that's part of
chess no it's one of the things that's
hardest to replicate
as a human as well or at least for my
playing
playing style
that usually when i i sacrifice i feel
like i'm
you know
i don't do it unless i feel like i'm
getting something like tangible uh in in
return and um like a few moves down the
line a few moves down the line you can
see that you can either retrieve the
material or you can put your opponent's
king under pressure or have some very
like very concrete
uh positional advantage this sort of
compensates for it
for instance
in chess so bishops and knights are
fairly equivalent
we both give them three points but
bishops are a little bit better and
especially a bishop pair is a lot better
than
than a bishop and a knight so or
especially two knights
depends on the position but
like
on average they are so like
sacrificing a pawn in order to get
get a bishop pair that's one of the most
common sacrifices in general you're okay
making a second yeah i mean it depends
on the situation but
generally that's fine and there are a
lot of openings that are based on that
that you sacrifice
upon for the bishop pair and then
eventually it's some sort of positional
equality um
so that's fine but um
the way alpha zero would
would sacrifice a knight or sometimes
two pawns three pawns
and you could see that it's looking for
some sort of positional domination but
it's
it's hard to understand and it's um it
was
really fascinating to see um
yeah in 2019 i was sacrificing a lot of
a lot of puns especially and it was
it was a great joy
unfortunately it's not so easy to
continue to do that people
people have found
more solid opening lines since that
don't allow me to to do that as often
i'm still trying both to get those
positions and still trying to
to learn the art of of sacrificing
pieces
so
uh demis also
made a comment that was interesting to
my newb chess brain which is one of the
reasons that chess is fun is because of
the quote creative tension between the
bishop and the knight so you're talking
about this
interesting um
difference between two pieces that
there's some kind of
how would you convert that i mean that's
like a poetic statement about chess
i think he said that why has chess been
played for such a long time why is it so
fun to play at every level that if you
can reduce it to one thing is is it's
the bishop
and the knight some kind of weird
dynamics that they create in chess is
there any truth to that
it sounds very good
i haven't tried a lot of other games but
i tried to play a little bit of shogi
and
for my noob shogi brain um comparing it
to chess what annoyed me about that game
is how much
the pieces suck
basically you have one rook and you have
one bishop that move like in chess and
the rest of the pieces are really
not very powerful so i think that's one
of the
attractions of chess like how powerful
especially the queen
is
which interesting i kind of think makes
it makes a lot of fun see you you think
power
is more fun
than like variety
no there is variety in chess as well
though just but not much more so than
like
like no no
they all move in different ways they're
all like weird
there's just all these weird patterns
and positions that can emerge the
difference in the pieces create all
kinds of interesting dynamics i guess is
what i'm trying to say yeah and i guess
it is quite fascinating that
all those years ago they created
the knight and the bishop
without probably realizing that they
would be
almost equally equally strong with such
different qualities yeah it's crazy that
this you know the like when you design
computer games
it's it's like an art form it's science
and an art to to balance it you know you
talk about starcraft and all those games
like so that you can have competitive
play at the highest level
with all those different units and
in in case of chess it's different
pieces
and they somehow designed a game that
was super competitive but there's
probably some kind of natural selection
that the chest just wouldn't last if it
was designed poorly yeah and i think the
the rules have changed
over time a little little bit
but i would be i mean speaking of games
and all that i'm also
interested to play
other
other games like
chess 960 or fisher random as they call
it like that you have 960 maps instead
of one
yeah so for people who don't know a
fisher random chest chest 960s yeah that
basically just means that the pawns are
in the same way and
the major pieces are
uh distributed randomly on the on the
last rank only that there have to be
obviously bishops of opposite color and
the king has to be in between the rooks
so that you can castle both ways oh you
can still castle and you can still
castle but it makes it interesting so
you still have
it still castles in the same way so
let's say the king is like
yeah what happens in that case yeah like
let's say the king is in the corner
um
so to to castle this side you have you
have to clear a whole lot of pieces
no the king would go here and the rook
would go there oh okay um and that's
happened in my games as well like i
forgot about castling
uh and i'd be like attacking a king over
here and then all of a sudden it escapes
to the other side i think um
i think fisher chess is
is good that it it's
the maps will
generally
be worse than regular chest like i think
the
starting position is as close to
ideal for creating a competitive game
as possible but they will still be like
interesting and diverse enough that you
can play very
very interesting games so when you say
maps there's 960 different options and
like what fraction of that creates
interesting games at the highest level
and this is something that a lot of
people are curious about because uh when
you challenge
a great chess player like yourself to um
to look at a random starting position
that feels like it pushes you to play
pure chess versus memorizing live yeah
for sure for sure but that's that's the
whole idea yeah that's what you want and
uh how hard is it to play i mean can you
talk about what what it feels like to
you to play with a random starting
position is there some intuition you've
been building up it's very very
different and i mean
understandably engines have
an even greater advantage in 960 than
they have in
in classical chess
no it's it's super interesting and
that's why i also
i really wish that
we uh
played more classical chess like
long games
four to seven hours and
in
fish random chess chest 960 because then
you really need
you really need that time even on the
first moves
what what usually happens is that you
get 15 minutes before the game you
you're getting told the position 15
minutes before the game and then you
you can think about it a little bit even
you know check the computer but that's
all the time
you have but then you really need to
figure it out then
like
some of the positions obviously are a
lot more interesting in than the others
in some of them it appears that like if
you don't play symmetrically
at
the start
then
you're probably going to be in a pretty
bad bad position what do you mean with
the pawns with the pawns yeah
why so that's the thing about that's the
thing about chess though so let's say
white opens with e4 which is which has
always been the most played move
there are many ways to meet that but the
most solid ways of playing has always
been the symmetrical response yeah uh
with the e5 and then there's the
the real lopez there's the there's the
petrov opening and and so on and
if you just banned symmetry on the first
move in chess
you would get more interesting games oh
interesting or you you get more decisive
um
decisive games so that's the good thing
about chess is that we've played it so
long that we've actually devised
non-symmetrical openings that are also
fairly equal
and
symmetry is a good default but yeah
symmetry is a good default and it's a
problem that
by playing symmetrical armed with good
preparation in regular chess is just a
little bit
too easy to uh it's a little bit too too
dryish and
um i guess if you analyzed
if you analyzed a lot in in just 960
then
um the um
a lot of the position would end up be
being um
pretty drawish as well um but
because the random starting point is so
shitty you're forced to you're actually
forced to play symmetrically like you
cannot actually try and play in a more
sort of interesting uh interesting
manner
uh is there any other kind of variations
that are interesting to you
oh yeah there are there are several
so no castling chess has been
has been promoted by former world
champion vladimir kramnik there have
been a few tournaments
with that not
any that i've participated in though um
i kind of like it also my coach uses
like non-castling
engines quite a bit to analyze
regular positions to just to get
a different
different perspective um so castling is
like a defensive thing so if you remove
castling it forces you to be more
offensive is that why
yeah it just yeah for for sure um it
seems like a i think it will be
different um
no castling probably forces you to be a
little bit more
defensive at the start or i would guess
so
because you cannot suddenly escape with
the
with with the kings that it's going to
make the game a bit slower at the start
but
i feel like eventually it's gonna
uh it's gonna make the more games more
um
uh well less drawish for for sure then
you have some weirder variants like
where the pawns can move both
diagonally and
and forward
and also you have self-captured chests
which is quite interesting so their
pawns can
or
commit suicide or yeah people can why
would that be a use a good move no
sometimes one of your pieces occupy a
square i mean
uh let me just set up a position let's
put it
put it like this
for instance like here i mean there are
a lot of ways to checkmate for white
like this for instance or there are
several ways
um but like this would be uh
would be uh
oh cool for people who are just
listening yeah basically you're bringing
in a knight close to the the whole the
the king the queen and so on yeah and
you replace the knight with a queen yeah
that's interesting so you have like a a
front
of of uh pieces and then you just
replace them with the with the second
yeah uh that's cool i mean that could be
interesting i think also maybe sometimes
in
it's just clearance basically it adds an
extra element of
of clearance so
i think there are many um
many uh different variants i don't think
any of them are
better than
the one that has been played for uh at
least a thousand years but um
it's certainly interesting to um
to see
so one of your goals is to reach the
feed a elo chest rating of 2 900.
maybe you can comment on how's this
rating calculated and what does it take
to get there
is it possible for a human being to get
there basically you play with a factor
of um 10
which means that if i were to play
against
um an opponent who's rated the same as
me i would be expected
to score fifty percent obviously and
that means that i would win five points
with a win and lose five points with the
draw and then equal if i if i draw if
your opponent is 200 points lower rated
you're expected to score 75 and and and
so on
and you establish that rating by playing
a lot of people and then it slowly
converges towards an estimate of how
likely you are to win or lose against
differences yeah and uh
my rating is obviously carried through
thousands of
of games um
right now my rating is 28 61
which is decent like i think that pretty
much
corresponds to to the level i have at
at the moment which means in order to
reach 2900
i would have to
either get better at chess which i think
is
fairly hard to
to do at least considerably better so
what i would need to do is
try and optimize
even more in terms of
the matchups preparations everything but
not not necessarily like selecting
tournaments and so on but like just
optimizing in terms of
of preparation like making sure i'm
i'm i never have any bad days and you so
you basically can't lose yeah i
basically can't [ __ ] up ever uh if i
wanna
if if i wanna reach that goal and so i i
think
reaching 2900 is pretty unlikely
the reason i've set the goal is
to have something to
to play for to have like
to have a motivation to
actually try and and be at my best when
i play because otherwise
i'm
playing to some extent mostly for for
fun these days uh in that i love to play
i love to try and win but i don't have
like a lot to
uh i don't have a lot to prove or
anything but that gives me at least the
motivation to try and
try and be at my best all the time which
i think is something to um to to aim for
so at the moment i'm quite
enjoying that process of
um uh of trying to um
yeah trying to optimize what would you
say motivates you in this
now and in the years leading up to now
the love of winning or the fear of
losing
so for
the world championship it's been fair of
losing for sure
other tournaments
love of winning is
a great great factor
and that's why i also get more joy from
from winning most tournaments than i do
for
winning the world championship because
then it's mostly been a
a relief i also think i enjoy winning
more now than i did
before
because i feel like i'm a little bit
more relaxed now
and um i also know that it's you know
it's not gonna last forever so every
every little win i
i appreciate um appreciate a lot more
now and and yeah in terms of fear for
losing like that's a huge
reason why i'm not gonna play the world
championship because
uh i it really didn't give me give me a
lot of joy it really was all about
avoiding losing
why is it that the world championship
really makes you feel this way
the anxiety so and when you say losing
do you mean
not just a match but like every single
position like like no it's just the fear
of a blunder
no i mean the blunder is okay like when
i sit down at the board then it's it's
mostly been fine because then i then i'm
focused on got it then i'm focused on
the game and i know i know that i can
play the game it's a time like in
between like knowing that
you know
i feel like losing is not an option
because it's the world championship and
because in a world championship there
are two players there's there's a winner
and a loser if i don't win a random
tournament that i play then you know i'm
usually
it depends on the tournament i might be
disappointed for sure
might even be pretty pissed but
ultimately you know you go on to the
next one with the world championship you
don't go on to the next one it's like
it's years
yeah and
it also has been like it's been a core
part of my identity for a while now that
i am world champion
and so there's not an option of
of losing that yeah
yeah there's uh you're gonna have to at
least for a couple of years carry the
the weight of having lost
you're
the former world champion now if you
lose
versus the current world champion
there are certain sports that
create that anxiety and others that
don't for example i think ufc like mixed
martial arts are a little better with
losing
it's understood like everybody loses
but there's not everybody though not
everybody not everybody not everybody
yes
could be bent to the chat
[Laughter]
but in boxing there is like that extra
pressure of like maintaining the
championship i mean maybe you could say
the same thing about the the ufc as well
so for you personally for a person
who loves chess
the first time you won the world
championship that was that was the big
that was the thing that was fun
yeah and then everything after
is like stressful yeah
uh essentially there was certainly
stress uh involved the first time as
well um
but
it was nothing compared to uh
compared to the others
so the only world championship after
that that i really enjoyed was the one
in 2018 against the american fabiano
corona and what that made that different
is
that i'd been kind of slumping for a bit
and he'd been on the rise so our ratings
were very very similar they were so
close that if at any point during the
during the match
i'd lost the game
um
he would have been ranked as number one
in world like our ratings were so close
that for each draw they didn't move
and and the game itself was close yeah
games themselves were very close uh i
i had a winning position in in the first
game that i couldn't really get anywhere
for a lot of games and he he had a
couple of games where he could
potentially have won um then in the last
game i was a little bit better
and eventually there they were all they
were all drawn but i felt like all the
way that this is an interesting match
against an an opponent who is at this
position
uh at this point equal to me
and so losing that would not have been
this disaster
because all in all the other matches i
would know that i would i've lost
against somebody
who i know
i'm much better than and that would be
would be a lot harder for me to um to
take well that's fascinating and
beautiful that the stress isn't from
losing this
because you have fun
you enjoy playing against somebody who's
as good as you may be better than you
that's exciting to you yeah uh it's it's
it's losing at this high stakes thing
that only happens
rarely to a person who's not as good as
you yeah and that's why it's also been
incredibly frustrating in other matches
like when i know
when we play draw after draw
and i can just i i know that i'm better
i can
sense during the game that i understand
it better than them but i cannot you
know i cannot get over the hump
so
you are
the best chess player in the world
and you not playing the world
championship really
makes the world championship not seem
important or i mean there's an argument
to be made for that
um is there anything you would like to
see if you had a change about the world
championship that would make it more fun
for you and better for the game of chess
period for everybody involved so i think
12 games or now 14 games that there is
for the world championship is a fairly
fairly low sample size if you want to
determine who the best player is or at
least the best player in that particular
matchup you need more more games and i
think
to some extent
if you're going to have a world champion
and call them the best players you best
player you got to make sure that the
format
increases the chance of finding
finding the best players so i think
having more games
and if you're going to have a lot more
games than you need to
then you need to decrease the time
control a bit
which
in turn i think is also
a good thing because
in very long time controls with
deep preparation you can sort of mask a
lot of your deficiencies as
as as a chess player
with because you have a lot of time to
to think and to defend and also
yeah you have deep preparation um
so i think those would be
for me to play um those would be
the the main the main the main things
more
more games and less time so you want to
see more games
and uh rules that emphasize pure chess
yeah but already
less time emphasize
emphasizes pure pure chess because
um
defensive
techniques are much harder to execute
with a little time what do you think is
there a sweet spot in terms of are we
talking about blitz is it how many
places a bit too fast um
to their credit this was suggested by by
feed as well
for a start to have two games per day
and let's say you have
45 minutes a game plus
15 or or 30 seconds per move that means
that each sessions will probably be
about
or a little less than two hours yeah
that would be would be a start also
what's
what we're playing in the tournament
that i'm playing here in
in in miami which is um four games a day
uh with uh 15 minutes plus 10 seconds
per move
those were would be um more interesting
than than the one
there is now and i i understand that
there are a lot of traditions people
don't want to change the world
championship that's that's all fine i
just think that um
the world championship
should do a better job of trying to
reflect who who's the best overall chess
player
so would you would you say like
if it's faster games you'd probably be
able to get a sample size of like
over 20 games 20 30 40 do you think
there's a number that's good over a long
period of time well i would prefer as
many as possible it's like a hundred
um yeah but let's say you play 12 days
two games a day you know that's 24. i
feel like that's already quite a bit
better you play like one black game one
white game
each day endurance wise that's okay yeah
i think that's fine like you will have
three days as well so i don't think that
will be will be a problem
um and also you have to prepare two sets
of openings for each day which makes it
more difficult for the teams preparing
yeah which i think is also good
let me ask you a fun question
if uh hikaru nakamura
was one of the two people
what i guess
i apologize yeah he could have he could
have finished second yeah so he lost the
last round of the candidates yeah and
you uh put maybe you can explain to me
internet speak opium is something you
tweeted
yeah
but if he if he got second
would you uh would you would you
just despite him still still play the
world championship that's internet
question and when the internet asks
samus the bide the dude abides
yeah uh sure thank you internet
so after the last match uh i did an
interview
uh right after where i talked about the
fact that i was unlikely to play the
next one
i'd spoken privately to both
family friends and
of course also my chess team that this
was likely going to be the last
the last match
um
what happened was that
right before the world championship
match there was this young player
already furuzia he had a dramatic rise
he rose to second in the world rankings
he was 18 then he's 19 now he qualified
for the candidates and it felt like
there was like
at least a half realistic possibility
that
he could be
the challenger for the next world
championship
uh and that sort of lit a fire under me
um do you like that yeah i like that i
like that a lot i love the idea of of
playing him in the next world
championship and
originally i just i was sure that i
wanted to announce right after the
tournament uh the match that this was it
i'm done i'm not playing the next one
but this lit a fire under me so that
made me think
you know
this actually motivates me and i just
wanted to get it out there for several
reasons
to create more hype about the candidates
to like sort of motivate myself a little
bit maybe motivate him
also obviously i wanted to give people
and people a heads up for the candidates
that
you might be playing for more than
more than first place like normally the
candidates is it's first place or best
it's like the world championship um
yeah and and then
so nakamura was one of many people who
just didn't believe me
which is fair
because i've talked before about not
not necessarily wanting
to to defend again
but i never like talked as concretely or
was as serious as this time so he simply
didn't believe me
and he was very vocal about that
and he said nobody believed me no no no
no players which may or may have not
have been true
and then yeah he lost he lost the last
game and he didn't didn't qualify
but to answer the question
no i'd already at that point decided
that i wouldn't wouldn't play
i would have liked it less
if he had
if he had not lost the last round but
the decision was but the decision was
already um was already made
does it uh does it break your heart a
little bit
that
you're walking away from it in all the
ways that you mentioned that it's just
not fun there's a bunch of ways that it
doesn't seem to bring out the best kind
of chess
it doesn't bring out the best out of you
and the particular opponents involved
does it just break your heart a little
bit like
you're walking away from something or
maybe the entire chess community is
walking away from
a kind of a historic event
that was so important in the 20th
century at least
so i won the championship in 2013. i
said no to
the candidates in 2011
i didn't particularly like the format i
also wasn't
i was just not in the mood i didn't want
the pressure
that
was connected with the world
championship and i was perfectly content
at the time to play the tournaments that
i did play um
also to to be ranked number one in the
world i was comfortable with the fact
that i knew that i was
i was the best and i didn't need a title
to
to show others um and
what happened later is
i suddenly decided to play um in 2013 i
liked they changed the format i liked it
better
um i just decided
you know it could be interesting let's
try and get this
um there really wasn't more than
more than that to it it wasn't like
fulfill fulfilling
lifelong dream or anything i just
thought you know let's let's play um
because it's just a cool tournament yeah
it's a cool school tournament it's a
good challenge you know
why not it's it's
something that's could be a motivation
it motivated me to get in the in the
best shape of my life that had been till
then so it was a good thing uh and
2013 match brought me a lot of a lot of
joy as well so i'm very very happy that
i that i did that but i never had any
thoughts that i'm gonna like keep the
title for for a long time immediately
after the match in 2013 i i mean also
before the match i'd spoken against
the fact that champion is seeded into
the final which i thought was unfair
after the match i
made a proposal that we have a different
system where the champion doesn't have
these privileges and
people's reaction both players and chess
community was general uh generally like
okay we're good we don't we don't want
that you keep your privileges
i was like okay whatever so you want to
fight for it every time
yeah
i want that
uh i have to ask just in case you have
an opinion uh if you can maybe from a
fantasy chess perspective uh analyze
uh ding vs nepo who wins
the current the two people that would
play
if you're not playing
generally i would consider that ding has
a slightly
better overall chest strength um what
are the strengths and weaknesses of each
if you can kind of
summarize it um
so
nepo he's
even better at calculating short lines
than i am
but he can sometimes like a little bit
of a little bit of depth uh like his in
short lines he's an absolute calculation
monster he's extremely uh he's extremely
quick but he can sometimes like a bit of
depth also recently
um he's improved his openings quite a
bit so now he
um he has a lot of a lot of good ideas
and he's very very
solid um ding is not quite as well
prepared but he has
an excellent understanding of
dynamics and imbalances in in chess i
would uh i would say what do you mean by
imbalances um imbalances like bishop
bishops against knights and material
imbalance you can take advantage of
those
yes i would say he's very very good at
that and understanding the you know the
dynamic factors as we call them like
material versus time
uh especially i think nepal got the
better of him and the candidates so
what's your sense why ding has an edge
in the in the championship i feel like
individual past results hasn't
necessarily been
a great indicator of world championship
results uh i feel like over overall
stress strength is more
more important i mean to be fair i only
think like ding has a very small edge
like difference is not big at all but
our individual head-to-head record was
probably the main reason that a lot of
people thought nepo had a good chance
against me as well it was like
four to one in his favor
before
the match but that was just another
example of why that may not necessarily
mean anything also in our case it was a
very
very low sample size i i think
about the size of of them of of the
match in total 14 games and that
generally doesn't
doesn't mean much how close were those
games would you say in your mind for the
previous championship
so that game 6 was a turning point where
you won
was there any doubt in your mind that
you know like if you do a much larger
sample size you'll get the better of
nippo no no larger larger sample size is
always good for me
so world championship it's it's a great
parallel to
to football
because it's a low scoring game
and
if the better
player or the better team scores
they win
most of the time oh that's generally for
for big for championships or in general
yeah for championships like they
generally
generally win uh because the other
slightly weaker team they're good enough
to
defend to make it very very difficult
for the others but when they actually
have to create the chances then they
have no chance and then it very often
ends with a blowout as it did in our our
match if i hadn't won game six it
probably would have been very very close
he might have edged it
there's obviously a bigger chance that i
i would have edged it but this is just
what happens a lot in in chess but also
in in football that matches our clothes
and then
they
somebody scores somebody scores and
things things changed and this gives
people the illusion
that the matchup was very close
yeah which
while actually it just means that
the nature of the game makes
the matches close very often but it's
always
much more likely that one of the teams
is gonna or one of the players is gonna
break away than the others and in other
matches as well even though
a lot of people before the match in 2016
against uh
um against karyakin there were people
who thought
before the match that i was massively
overrated as as as a favorite and
that
essentially
the match was pretty pretty close like
whatever uh
60 40 or some people even stayed like 55
45 and what i felt was that the match
went very very wrong for me and
i still won
and some people saw that as an
indication that the pre-match
probabilities were probably a bit closer
than people thought well
i would look at it in that in the way
that everything went wrong and i i still
i still won which probably means i was
pretty big favorite to begin with i do
have a question to you about that match
but first
so sergey karjakin was originally a
qualifier for the candidate tournament
but was disqualified
for breaching the fide code of ethics
after publicly expressing approval for
the
2022 russian invasion ukraine when you
look at the cold war and some of the us
versus russian games of the past does
politics
that some of this geopolitics politics
ever
creep its way into the game do you feel
the pressure the immensity of that as it
does sometimes for the olympics you know
these big nations playing each other
competing against each other almost like
fighting out
you know in a friendly way the battles
the tensions that they have in the space
of geopolitics
yeah i think it still does
so the president of the world chess
federation who was just re-elected is is
is a russian like i like him personally
uh for sure
but he is quite connected to the kremlin
like and it's
quite clear that the kremlin considers
it at least a semi-important goal to
bring the chess crown home to to russia
so it's still it's still definitely a a
factor and i mean i can answer for in
the karjakin case like i don't have a
strong
opinion on on whether
he should have been banned or not
obviously i don't agree with anything
that he
he says
but
in principle i think
that you should
ban either no russians or all russians
i'm generally
not
particularly against either but
i don't
love
banning wrong opinions even if they are
as reprehensible as uh asses have been
yeah there's something about
the world chess championships or the
olympics
where it feels like banning is
counterproductive to the alleviating
some of the conflicts
we don't know this is the thing though
yeah we really don't know about the the
long-term
conflicts and a lot of people try to do
the right the right thing in this sense
which i don't really blame at all it's
just that
it's just that we don't know and
i guess sometimes
there are other ways you want to try and
try and help as well
see like within the competition within
some of those battles of us versus
russia or so on of the past there's also
between the individuals
um maybe you'll disagree with us but
from a spectator perspective there's
still a camaraderie
like at the end of the day there's a
thing that unites you which which is
this like appreciation
of the fight over the chessboard it's um
even if you hate each other yeah
for sure i think for
every every match that spin
you would briefly discuss the game with
your opponent after
after the game no matter how much you
hate each other and i i think that's
lovely uh and kasparov i mean he was
quoted like one somebody in his team
asked him like why why are you talking
to
the carp of after the game like he
you hate that guy and he's like yeah
sure but he's the only one who
understands me yeah the only one who
understands so that's uh no i think
that's really lovely and i would love to
see that in other
in other areas as well that you can
regardless of what happens you can have
you can have a good chat about the game
you can you can just talk about
the ideas with people who who understand
what you what you understand
so
if you're not playing the world
championships there's a lot of people
who are saying that perhaps the world
championships don't matter anymore
do you think there's some truth to that
i said that back a long time ago as well
that
for me
i don't know if
it never happened so i don't know what
would have happened but i was thinking
like the moment
that i realized that i'm not the best
player in the world like i i felt like
morally i have to renounce the world
championship title you know
because it doesn't mean anything yeah as
long as you're not the best player
so the ratings really tell a bigger
a clearer
story i think so at least just at least
over time like i'm a lot more proud of
my streak of being rated number one in
the world which is
now since i think
the summer of 2011.
uh i'm a lot more proud of of that than
than the world championships
how much
anxiety or or even fear do you have
before making a difficult decision on
the chessboard so it's a high stakes
game
how nervous do you get how much anxiety
do you have in all that calculations
you're sitting there for 10-15 minutes
because you're in a fog there's always a
possibility of a blunder of a mistake
are you anxious about it are you afraid
of it
really depends
um i have been i have been at times
i think the most nervous i've ever been
was
game 10 of uh
the world championships in 2018.
i know that was just a thrilling game
i was black
i basically abandoned the queen side at
some point to attack him on the king
side and i knew that
my attack if it doesn't work i'm gonna
lose but i had so much adrenaline so
that was that was fine i thought i was
gonna win
then at some point i realized that it's
not so clear
and then my time was ticking and i was
just getting so nervous i i still
remember
what happened like we played this time
trouble phase where he had fair little
time but i had even less
and
i just remember i can't remember much of
it just that when it was over i was just
so
relieved because then it was clear the
position was probably gonna
figure out and um in a draw otherwise
i'm often nervous before games but when
i get there
it's all business and especially when
i'm playing well
i'm never afraid of of losing when i
when i play
because i trust yeah i trust my
instincts i trust my
my skills how much psychological
intimidation is there from you to the
other person from the other person to
you
i think people would play a lot better
if they played
against an anonymous me i would love to
our people are scared of you i i would
love to to have a tournament online
where let's say you play 10 of the best
players in the world
and you don't for each round you don't
know who you're playing
would be
that's an interesting question you know
like there's these like videos where
people eat mcdonald's the burger king or
diet coke versus
diet pepsi would people be able to tell
they're playing you
like from the style of play do you think
um or from the strength of play
if there was a decent sample size sure
uh and what about you would you be able
to tell uh others
in like one game
very unlikely what what sample size
would you need to tell accurately i feel
like that's the science yeah i
i think 20 games would help a lot per
person yeah
but
i know that they've already developed ai
bots that are pretty good at recognizing
somebody's style
okay which is um which is quite
fascinating
[Music]
it'd be fascinating if those bots were
able to summarize the style somehow
maybe great attacking chess like some of
the same characteristics you've been
describing like great at short
line calculations all that kind of stuff
yeah
no but really all the best chess players
there are basically just two camps
people who are good at long longer lines
or
or shorter lines it's the hair and the
tortoise basically
and sometimes you know
i feel like i'm
the closest you can get to a a hybrid of
those
because you got both the
you're good in every position the middle
game and the end game yeah and also i
can i can think to some extent both
rapidly and deeply which a lot of people
they can't do both um but i mean to to
answer your question from before i think
yeah i sometimes can get a little bit
intimidated by my opponent but
it's mostly if there's something unknown
if it's mostly if if it's something that
i
don't understand fully and i do think
especially when i'm playing
while people they just play more timidly
against me than they do against each
other sometimes
without even realizing it and i
certainly use that to my my advantage if
i sense that my opponent is
apprehensive if i sense that
they are not going to necessarily take
all their chances it just means that i
can take more risk
and um
i always try and try and find that
balance to shake them up a little bit
yeah what what's been the toughest loss
of your career that you remember would
that be the um
the world championship match oh yeah for
sure uh can you take game aids in 2016.
and who was it against against karjakin
in
in new york uh can you take it through
the story of that game um where were you
uh
before that game in terms of game one
through seven
yeah so game one and two not much
happened uh games three and four i was
winning in both of them and um
normally i should definitely converted
both
i couldn't partly due
to good defense on his part but mostly
because
i just
i messed up
and then after that
games five
six and seven not much
happened i was getting impatient that
at that point um so for
game eight i was probably ready to take
a little bit more risks than i i had
before which
i guess was insane because i knew that
he couldn't beat me unless i beat myself
like he wasn't strong enough to outplay
me
and that was leading to impatience
somehow and impatience no because i knew
that i was better yeah i knew that i was
better i knew that i just needed to win
one game and then the match is over yeah
that's what happened in in 2021 as well
like when i won the first game against
napo i knew that the match was over
unless i like [ __ ] up royally then he's
not gonna be able to beat me
so what happened was that
i played a kind of an innocuous opening
as white
just trying to get a game trying to get
him out of book as soon as possible then
can you elaborate innocuous get him out
of the book
no but basically i i set up pretty
defensively i was watching i wasn't
really crossing into his half at the
start at all i was just
i played more like a system more
than like a concrete opening it was like
i'm gonna set up my pieces this way you
can set them up however you want and
then later where sort of the armies are
gonna meet i'm not gonna try and bother
you at the start and that means
you can have with as many pieces as
possible kind of pure chest in the
middle game yeah
without any of the the lines
the the standard lines in the opening
exactly
and so there was at some point a couple
of exchanges then some maneuvering
a little bit better then he was sort of
equalizing and then i started to take
too many risks and i was still sort of
fine um but
then at some point i realized that
i'd gone a bit too far and i had to be
really careful then i just froze
i just completely froze
uh mentally yeah mentally what happened
i realized that i mean all the thoughts
of
i might lose this what have i done
why did i take so many risks i knew that
i could have drawn at any moment just be
patient don't
give him these opportunities
what triggered that like face transition
in your mind no it was one thing or no
it was just a position on the board like
realizing like there was one particular
move he played that i missed and then
like
and then i i realized that this could
potentially not go go my way so then i
made another couple of mistakes and he
to his credit like once he realized he
had the chance he was
like
he knew that this was his one chance he
had to take it
and so he did
and
yeah that's that's the the worst i've
ever felt after
um after a chess game i realized that
i'm probably gonna lose my title against
somebody who's not even close to my
level
and i've done it because of my own
stupidity most of all
and that was
really really um
at the time like i was all in my
own head that was
that was hard to deal with and i felt
like i didn't really
recover too much
for the next game so what i did there
was a free day after the eighth game so
i did something that i never did at any
other world championship like i
after game eight i just
i got drunk with my team
and that's not a standard procedure no
no that's that's the only time that's
happening um
in the world championship during the
match so yeah
i just tried to forget uh but still
before game nine game nine i was a
little bit more relaxed
but i was still a bit nervous then game
nine i almost lost as well
and then only game ten
game ten i was still i wasn't in a great
mood i was really really tense
um the opening was good
i had some advantage i was getting
optimistic then i made one mistake
he could have forced the draw and then
the old all the negativity came back
like
i was thinking during game like how i'm
gonna play for win with black in the
next game like what
what am i doing
and then you know eventually it ended it
ended well i didn't find the right line
i ground him down actually i played at
some point pretty well in the end game
and um
after that game like there was such a
weight
a little bit lifted no
i i after that there was like no thought
of losing the match whatsoever i knew
that okay i'd basically
gotten away with um
not with murder but
get gotten away with something
what can you say about the after game a
where are the places you've gone in your
mind do you go to some dark places we're
talking about like depression do you
think about quitting at that point
no i mean i i think about quitting
every time i lose the class
or at least i used to yeah like
especially if it's in a stupid way
i'm thinking like okay if i'm gonna
i'm gonna play like this if i'm gonna do
things that i know are wrong then you
know i might as well quit
no that's happened that's happened a
bunch of a bunch of times and
i definitely gotten a bit more carefree
about losing these days which it's not
necessarily a good thing like my hatred
of losing
led to me
not losing a lot and
it also lit the fire under me that
i think my performance after losses in
in classical chess over the last 10
years is like over 2 900. like i really
play well after
a loss even though it's really really
unpleasant so
apparently like
i don't think the way that i dealt with
them is particularly healthy but it's
worked
it's worked so far but then you've
discovered now love
for winning to where ultimately
longevity wise
creates more fun yeah for sure yeah
what's the perfect day in the life of
magnus carlson on a day of a big chess
match
it doesn't have to be world championship
but if if if it's a chess match you care
about what uh what time do you wake up
what do you eat
well it depends on when the game is but
let's say the game is at three um i'll
probably
wake up uh pretty
late at about
11
then i'll
go for go for a walk
might listen to some podcasts
maybe i'll spend a little bit of time
looking at some you know some nba game
from last night or whatever
to not chess related stuff no no no uh
then i'll
i'll get back i'll have a big lunch like
usually like a big omelet with a bunch
of salad and stuff
then go to the game
win
like a very nice clean game
this is a perfect day just go back after
relax
like the the things that make me the
happiest at tournaments is just having a
good routine and uh feeling feeling well
um i don't like it when
too much is happening around me so the
tournament that i came from now
was
um the chess olympiad which is the team
event
so we were team norway we did horribly
yeah i like i did okay but the team in
general did did horribly uh
italy
uh no no italy beat us but uzbekistan
won in the end they were this amazing
team of young players it was really it
was really impressive but the thing is
like we had a good camaraderie in the
team we had our meals together we played
a bit of football went swimming
and
i couldn't understand why things went
wrong and i still don't understand but
the thing is for me it was all very nice
but now i'm so happy to be on my own at
a tournament just to have my own
routines not see too many people yeah
otherwise just have like a very small
team of people that i see
you are a kind of celebrity now so
you know people within the chess
tournament and outside recognize you
want to socialize want to tell you about
how much you mean to them how much you
inspire them all that kind of stuff does
that get in the way for you when you're
like trying to really focus on on the
match are you able to block that like
are you able to enjoy that those little
interactions and still keep your focus
yeah most of the time that's uh that's
fine as long as it's not too much but i
have to admit
when i'm at home in
norway like i rarely
go out with like
without um big headphones and something
uh oh look at this guy on my no not just
black guys just to block out the world
yeah otherwise
um don't make eye contact yeah
so the thing is
people in general are nice i mean people
they wish me well
and
they don't like bother me also when i
have the headphones on i don't notice as
much people like turning around and yeah
and all of that so i can be more of in
my own world
so i like that yeah uh what about after
the the in this perfect day after the
game
do you try to analyze what happened do
you try to think through systematically
or do you just kind of loosely think
about like no i just loosely think about
it i i've never been very structured in
in that sense um
i know that
it was always recommended that you
analyze your your own games but i i
generally felt
that i mostly had a good idea about that
like nowadays i will like loosely
see what the engine says at at a certain
point if i'm curious about that
otherwise i
usually move on to the next
what about
diet you said almond and salad and so on
i heard in your conversation with the uh
with the other magnus magnus number two
about
your do you had like this bet about meat
when are you gonna go vegan if you lose
i forget which vegetarian though uh
vegetarians
and uh you both have an admiration for
me is there um
is there some aspect about optimal
performance that you look for in food
like
maybe eating only like once or twice a
day or a particular kind of food like
meat heavy diet is there anything like
that or you just try to have fun with
the food
i think
um
whenever i'm at tournaments like
it's very natural to eat at least for me
to eat only twice a day so usually i do
that when i'm at home as well before so
you you do eat before the tournament
though you don't you don't play fasted
no no no um
but i try not to eat too heavy before
the game or
in general to avoid
sugary stuff to have
a pretty stable
blood sugar level
because that's the easiest way to make
mistake that your your energy levels
just suddenly suddenly drop and they
don't necessarily mean need to be too
high as long as they're pretty stable
yeah have you ever tried playing fasted
like you know like
uh intermittent fasting so oh playing
without having eaten i mean the reason i
asked you know uh i've especially when
you do a low carb diet when i have done
a personally low carb diet i'm able to
fast for a long time like you once a day
maybe
uh twice a day but i just the mind is
most focused and like really difficult
thinking tasks when it's fasted it's an
interesting a lot of people kind of talk
about that
yeah but you're able to kind of like
zoom in and if you're doing a low carb
diet you don't have this energy the
energy stable no
that is true maybe that would be
interesting to try so what's happened
for me if i played a few tournaments
where i've had food poisoning
and then that generally means that
you're both sleep deprived and you have
no energy yeah and what i've found is
that
it makes me to some it makes me very
calm of course because i don't have
the energy and it makes me super
creative
like interesting being sleep deep
probably i think in general makes you
creative
just the first thing that goes away is
the ability to do the simple things
that that's that's what if it affects
you the most like you cannot be precise
so i'm that's the only thing i'm worried
about like if if i'm faster that i won't
be
it won't be
[Music]
precise when i play
but you might be more creative
it's an interesting trusted yeah
potentially what about you have been
known to on a rare occasion play drunk
is there mathematical formula for
sort of on the x-axis how many drinks
you had and then the y-axis
your performance slash creativity is
there like an optimal for like uh one of
the would you suggest for the feeding
world championship that people would be
required to drink would that change
things in interesting ways yeah not at
all um
maybe for rapid but for for blitz i
think if you're playing blitz you're
mostly playing on
on short calculation and intuition and i
think
those are probably enhanced if you've
had
a little bit of a little bit to drink
can you uh explain the uh
the physiology of why that's why it's
enhanced or the you're just you're
thinking less you're more confident
oh yeah i think
i think it's just confidence i think
also like a lot of people
feel like they're better at
speaking languages for instance if
they've drunk a little bit it's just
like removing these barriers yeah i
think that it's it's a little bit of
the same in inches
in 2012 i played the world bliss
championship and then
i i was doing horribly for
for a long time i also had food
poisoning there i couldn't play at all
for for three days so there before the
last break i was like in the middle of
the pack like in
i don't know
20th place or something and so i decided
like
as the last
last gasp i'm gonna go to the mini bar
and just have a few drinks
and um what happened is that i came back
and i was suddenly relaxed
uh and i was playing fast and i was
playing confidence and i thought i was
playing so well
i wasn't playing nearly as well as i
thought
but it still helped me like i won my
remaining eight games and if
there had been one more round i probably
would have won the whole thing but
finally i was
i was second so generally i wouldn't
recommend that
but maybe as the last resort sometimes
like if you feel that you have the
ability like obviously none of this
is remotely relevant if you don't feel
like you have the ability to begin with
but if you like if you feel like you
have the ability there are just factors
that
make it impossible for you to um
to show it like numbing your mind a bit
can probably be a good thing yeah what's
interesting is especially during
training you have all kinds of sports
that i've interacted with a lot of
athletes in grappling sports
it's different when you train under
extreme exhaustion for example you start
becoming
you start to discover interesting things
you start being more creative yeah a lot
of people um
in at least in
brazilian jiu jitsu they'll they'll
smoke weed you know it does it creates
this kind of anxiety and relaxation that
kind of
enables that creative aspect it's
interesting for training of course you
can't rely on one of those things too
much but it's cool to throw in like a
few drinks every once in a while to uh
yeah one first of all to relax and have
fun
and two to kind of try things
differently to unlock a different part
of your brain yeah for sure
uh what about supplements
do you uh
you a coffee guy oh no um
i quite like the taste of coffee
uh i've but the thing is i've never had
a job
so i've never needed to wake up early
yeah so
my
thought is basically that if i'm tired
i'm tired that's fine yeah then i'll you
know then i'll
work it out so i don't want to ever
um
make my brain get used to
get used to coffee like if you see me
drinking coffee that's
that probably means that i'm
massively
massively hungover and i don't
i just want i want to try
anything to to make my brain work yeah
that's interesting but for a lot of
people like you said taste of coffee for
a lot of people coffee
is part of a certain kind of ritual yeah
for sure enjoy you know so
no
i know that i would enjoy it a lot yeah
though you don't want to rely on it
yeah
i also like the taste so there's no
problem there
what about
exercise
so
how does that what like what what you
know a lot of people talk about the
extreme
um stress that chest puts in your body
physically and mentally how do you
prepare for that to be physically
mentally is it just through playing
chess or do you do cardio any any of
that kind of stuff
this is kind of it up and down like as i
said in 2013
i was in
i was in great shape like
i mean generally i was exercising doing
sports every day either playing football
or
um
tennis or even other other sports
otherwise if i couldn't do that i would
try and take my my bike for for a ride
i had a few training camps and i played
tennis against one of my my seconds like
he's not
a super fit guy but he's always been
very good at tennis and i never like
played in any organized way um and that
was like that was a that was the perfect
exercise because
i was
running around enough to make the games
pretty competitive
uh and it means meant that he had to run
a bit less as well but he was just he
said like
he was shocked that if we played like
for
two hours i wouldn't flinch
at all
interesting so like a combination of fun
and uh the differential between skill
results in good cardio yeah yeah but it
is it's just that um
so in those days i was i was pretty uh
i was pretty fit in that sense i've
always liked doing sports but at times
you know
i i think in winter especially like i
never had like a schedule so at times
i'll let myself
go a little bit
uh and i've always kind of done it more
for
for fun then like for a concrete
benefit but now i'm at least after the
uh pandemic i was not in great shape so
now i'm trying to
to get back get better
get better habits and
and so on but um
i feel like i've always been
the
poster boy for
making being fit a big
thing in chess and i always felt that it
was it's not really deserved because i
never liked doing weights much at all
i
run a bit at times but i never liked it
too much you just love playing sports
just love playing sports so that i think
people confuse that because i'm i'm not
like massively athletic but i but i do i
am decent at
uh at sports and that's that's sort of
helped build that
that perception even though others who
are top level chess players
um they're more fit like karana for
instance he's really really
um
his body is really really strong it's
just that he doesn't he like goes to the
gym and yeah
he doesn't play sports that's that's
them that's the difference and the thing
about sports is also is just
uh
it's an escape it helps you forget for
for a brief moment about like the the
obsessions the pursuits of of the main
thing which is chess yeah for
uh for sure and i think it's it also
helps
your main pursuit
to feel that you're um
even if not mastering but like
doing well in something um in something
else like
i found that if i just juggle a ball
that makes me feel better before a game
so
juggalo football yeah yeah
skilled activity that you can improve on
over time it's like flexes the same kind
of muscle but on the thing that you're
much worse at yeah uh it focuses you
relaxes you that's really interesting
what uh what's the perfect day in the
life of magnus carlson when he's
training
so like what's a good training regimen
in terms of
you know daily kind of training do you
have to put in across many
days months and years
to just keep yourself sharp in terms of
chess
i would say when i'm at home i do very
very little
deliberate practice
i've never been that guy at all like
i've i could never force myself to
just sit down and work so deliberate
practice
just to maybe you can educate me for
some
grand masters what would that look like
just doing puzzles kind of thing or yeah
doing puzzles and opening analysis that
would be the main things
studying games
just studying games yeah a little bit
but i feel like
that's something that i do
but it's not deliberate it's
like reading our article or reading a
book got it like i love chess books i'll
read just
anything
and i'll find something interesting so
chess books that are like on openings
and stuff like that or just books that
go over different games yeah um both
books on
so there are three main categories there
are books on openings and there are
books on strategy and there are books on
chess history and i find all of them
very very interesting like what fraction
of the day would you say you have a
chessboard floating somewhere in your
head
meaning like you're thinking about it
probably be a better question to ask how
many hours a day i don't have a chess
blog
i mean it could be just floating there
and nothing is happening but like i i
often do it parallel to some other
activity though and what what does that
look like like are you daydreaming like
different
is it actual positions you're just
[ __ ] around with like fumbling with
different pieces in your head
often i've looked at a
at the random game on my phone for
instance or
in a book and then my brain just keeps
going at the same position analyzing it
and often it goes all the way you know
to the end game and those are actual
games or you conjure up like fake games
no they were often based on real games
uh and then i'm i'm thinking like oh but
it wouldn't be more interesting if the
pieces were a little bit different and
then often i play it out from there
so you don't have uh
like you don't sit behind a computer or
a chess board and you lay out the pieces
and no
i'm not at all
a poster board for deliberate practice i
could never i could never work that way
my first coach
he gave me some
exercises to do at home
sometimes but he realized at some point
uh that wasn't gonna work yeah because i
wouldn't do it really or enjoy it
so what
he would do instead is that at the
school where i had the trainings with
him there was
this
massive chess library so it's just like
yeah pick pick up books you can have
anything
you can have anything you want uh just
pick up books you like and then you give
back the next time so that's kind of
what i did instead yeah i just
absolutely rated the and then my next
tournament i will try out one of the
openings from that book if it was an
opening book and so on so does it feel
like a struggle like challenging
like to be thinking those positions or
is it fun and relaxing no it's
completely fine i don't
like if it's a difficult position to
figure out you know like to calculate
then i go on to something else okay
like if i can't figure it out then
you know i'll go on
change it so that's easier to figure out
there was a point in your life where
cause probably was interested in being
your coach
or traily's training with you why why
did you choose not to go with him that's
pretty bold move
was there a good reason for this no um
the first
like homework exercise he gave me was
to analyze like he picked out i think
three four of my worst losses and she
wanted me to analyze them and give him
my thoughts and it wasn't that there
were painful losses or anything that
that was a problem i just didn't really
enjoy
that
also i felt that
this whole structured approach and
everything yes i just felt like from the
start it was was a hassle so i loved the
idea of being able to pick his brain
but everything else i just
you know couldn't see myself
i couldn't see myself enjoying and
at the end of the day i did then and
always have played
for fun that's always been
my main reason so it's great that you
had the confidence to sort of
basically turn down the approach
of one of the greatest chess players of
all time at that time probably the
greatest chess player of all time
i i don't think i thought of it that way
i just thought this is not for me i'm
going to try another way
i don't think i was particularly
thinking that this is my one opportunity
or anything it was just yeah i don't
enjoy this let's try something else when
you were 13 you faced kasparov
uh and he wasn't able to beat you
can you go through that match what did
that feel like how important was that
was that how epic was that
we played three games
uh i lost two and i drew one
right but one draw no the one draw um
and but didn't you say that you kind of
had a better position in that yeah i
remember that day very well there was a
blitz game this was a rapid tournament
and there was a blitz tournament the day
before
which determined
the the pairings for the rapids and for
people who don't know
super short games are called bullet kind
of short games are called blitz
semi
short games are called rap yeah
and classic chess i guess is like very
super long yeah uh yeah basically bullet
just never played over the board so in
terms of where the board chess blitz is
the shortest rapid is like a hybrid
between
classical and
blitz you need to have the skills for
both and then classical is it's like the
blitz tournament which
didn't go so well uh like i got a couple
of wins but i was
beaten badly in a lot of games including
by gary and so there was the pairing
that i had to play him which is pretty
exciting so i remember i was so tired
after the blitz tournament like i slept
for 12 hours or something then i woke up
like okay i'll turn on my computer i'll
search chess space for kasparov
and we'll go from there
so before that i hadn't spent like a lot
of time specifically studying his games
it was super intimidating because
a lot of these openings i knew
i was like oh he was the first one to
play that oh that was his idea i
actually didn't know that
so i was a bit intimidated before we
played then of course the first game
he
arrived a bit late because they changed
the time from the first day to the other
which is a bit strange and but everybody
else had noticed it but him
um
then he tried to surprise me in the
opening i think like psychologically the
situation was not so easy for him like
clearly it would be embarrassing for him
if he didn't win
both games against me
then
like i was spending way too much time on
my moves because i was playing kasparov
i was double checking everything too
much like normally i would would be
playing pretty fast in those days
and then at some point
i
calculated better than him he missed a
crucial detail another much better
position
i couldn't convert it though i knew what
line i had to go for
uh in order to have a chance to win but
i thought like i'll play a bit more
carefully maybe i can win still i
couldn't
and then i lost the
second game pretty badly which
it wasn't majorly upsetting but
i felt that i had two black games
against caspar both in the blitz and the
rapid and i lost both of them without
any fight whatsoever i wasn't happy
about that at all that was like less
than i i thought i could be able to
to do so
to me
yeah i was proud of that but it was a
gimmick
that was like a very strong i am but had
gm strength
i was like
it can't happen
that a player of that strength makes a
draw against gary once yeah but okay for
people but i mean i understand i'm 13
but like
still i've felt a bit more gimmicky than
anything i mean i guess it's it's a good
thing that made me noticed uh but apart
from that
wasn't yeah and for people who don't
know i am as international master and uh
gm was grandmaster and you were just on
the i guess on the verge of becoming a
young youngest grandmaster ever i was
the second
youngest ever i think i'm like the
seventh youngest now i mean these kids
these days kids these days yeah
yeah no but uh but i was the youngest
scrum master at the time uh
in the world yeah yeah so
there is a you know you say it's
gimmicky but there's a romantic notions
the
especially as things have turned out
right like
no for sure and have you talked to gary
since then about that no not really i
don't i think he's embarrassed the [ __ ]
he's still bitter you think no i don't
think he's he's bitter but i i think the
game in itself was
was a bit embarrassing for him uh so
even he can't see past
like
i think he's completely fine with that i
think like in retrospect it's a good
story he appreciates he appreciates that
i don't think that's the problem but it
never made sense for me to broach the
subject with him
yeah i i just
it's funny just having interacted with
gary now having talked to you there is a
little thing you still hate losing
no matter how beautiful like that moment
is because it's like
it in in a way it's the passing of the
baton from like one great champion to
another yeah right but like you you
still just don't like the fact that you
didn't play a good game from gary's
perspective like he still was just
annoyed probably that yeah he could have
played better and we did
so we did work together in 2009 quite a
lot
and
that corporation ended um
early 2010 but we did play a lot of
training games
in 2009 which was
interesting because he was still very
very strong
and at that time it was fairly equal
like he was up playing me quite a bit
but i was i was fighting well so it was
it was pretty um
pretty even then um so i mean i
appreciate those games a lot more than
some random game from when i was 13. and
i maybe i just don't know what i'm
talking about but
i always found it
at least based on that game you couldn't
tell that i was gonna take his
that i was gonna take his part like i
made a
horrible blunder and lost to an uzbek
kid in the world rapid championship in
in 20
18.
and i mean granted he was part of the
team that now won gold in the chess
olympia but he wasn't a crucial part he
barely played any games like it wasn't
like i would think that he would become
world champion because he beat me
i'm always skeptical of those who said
that they knew that i was gonna be world
champion after uh after that game or at
all at that time i mean
it was easy to see that i would become a
very very strong player uh everybody
could see that but
to be the best in the world or one of
the best ever it's true
it is hard to say but i do remember
seeing messi when he was 16 and 17.
um but hasn't that happened with other
players though yeah but i i pers i just
had a personal experience he did look
different than
there's like magic there you maybe you
can't tell he would be uh
one of the greatest ever but there's
there's still magic but you're right
most of the time we're trying to project
we see a young kid being an older person
you just start to think okay this could
be the next great person then we forget
when they don't become that yeah exactly
that's i think what happens
but when it does maybe
or maybe some people are just
so good at seeing these patterns that
they can actually aren't you supposed to
do that kind of thing with fantasy
football like see the long shot and bet
on them and then they turn out to be
good
no you you make a lot of a lot of long
shot bats and then
some of them come good
and then people call you a genius for
making the bet well let me ask you the
goat question again from fantasy
perspective
can you make the case for the greatest
chess player of all time
for each yourself magnus carlsen for
gary kasparov i don't know who else
bobby fisher mikhail tall
anyone else um
for uh hikaru nakamura
just kidding yeah uh i i think i'll i
can make a case for um myself
for for gary and for fisher so i'll
start with fisher uh for him
it's very very simple
he was ahead of his time but that's like
intangible you can say that about a lot
of people but he had a
peak from
1970 to
72 when he was so much better
than the others he won 20 games in a row
also the way that he played
was so powerful and with so few mistakes
that
he just had no opposition there so he
had just a peak that's been
better than
anybody like the gap between the
infrastructure
and others have was
greater than it's ever been
in history at any other time uh and that
would be the argument for
for him
for gary he's played in a very
competitive
era
and he's beaten several generations he
was the best
well he was the consensus best player i
would say for
almost 20 years which nobody else has
has done in
at least in recent time and the
longevity that the longevity for sure
also at his peak
he um was not quite the level of um
of fisher in terms of the gap but it was
similar to or i think even a little bit
better than than mine as for me
i'm of course
unbeaten as a world champion in in five
tries i've been
world number one for 11 years straight
in an even more competitive era than
gary i have the highest chest rating of
all time i have the longest streak ever
without
losing a game
i think for me the main argument would
be about the era where there's
the
engines have leveled
the
playing field so much that it's it's
harder to dominate and still
i haven't always been uh clear number
one but i've always i've been number one
for 11 years and
for a lot of the time the gap has been
pretty big
so i think there are decent arguments
for for all of them um i've said before
and i haven't changed my mind that gary
generally urges it because of the
longevity in in the competitive era but
um
there are arguments but people also talk
about you in terms of the style of play
so it's not just about dominance or the
height or the
it's like
just the the creative genius of it the
yeah but i'm not interested in that
in terms of greatest of all time uh i'm
not interested in in
in questions of style
so you so for messi you don't give
credit for the style uh for the
stylistic i like i like um no i like
watching it i just but you're not gonna
give
points for the
so messy no i mean
because of the finishing
yeah it's it's the um the no it's not
because of the finishing it's because of
his overall impact
on the game is higher than anybody
else's okay
he contributes
he just contributes more to winning than
anybody else does
what's um so you're somebody who was
advocated for and has done quite a bit
of study of classic games what would you
say is um
i mean maybe
the number one or maybe top three
games of chess ever played
that doesn't interest me at all you
don't think of the nose no i don't think
of it i mean i tried to i find the games
interesting i tried to learn from them
but like trying to to rank them has
never interested me what what what games
pop out to you is like super interesting
then is there is there things like where
idea like old school games where there
was like interesting ideas
that
uh
um that you go back or like you you find
surprising and pretty cool that that
that those ideas were developed like
that
is there something that jumps to mind
yeah there are several games of
young kasparov like before he became
world champion
if you're going to ask for like my
favorite player or favorite style that's
probably youngest
younger can you describe stylistically
or in any other way what what yanka's
was like that you're that you like uh it
was just an overflow energy in his play
so aggressive yeah extreme extremely
aggressive dynamic jazz it probably
appeals to me
a lot because
these are the things that i cannot do as
well
that it just feels very special to me
but yeah in terms of games
i never never thought about that too
much
is there uh
memories big or small weird surprising
uh just any kind of beautiful anecdote
um from your chest career like stuff
that pops out that people might not know
about the stuff when you look back it
just makes you smile
no so i'll tell you about
the um
most satisfying tournament victory of my
career
um so that was the norwegian
championship under 11 in 2000
before that
tournament i was super anxious
because i started like kind of late at
chess i i played my first tournament
when i was eight and a half and a lot of
my competitors had already played for
for a couple of years or even three four
years at that point
and the first time i so i played the
under 11 championship in 99 i was like a
little over the middle of the pack i'd
never played against any of them before
so i didn't know what to expect at all
and then over the next year
i was like edging a little bit closer in
each tournament i felt like i was
getting a little bit better
and
when we had the championship i knew that
i was ready that i was now at the same
level of
the best players i was so anxious to to
show it i remember i was just
the feeling of excitement and
nervousness before the tournament was
incredible
the tournament was weird
because i started out i gave away a draw
to a weaker player
whom i shouldn't have drawn to and then
i drew against the other guy
who was clearly like the best or second
best
and and at that point i thought it was
over
because i thought he wouldn't he
wouldn't give away points to others
and then the very next day he lost to
somebody
so then the rest of the tournament it
was just like i was always like playing
my game watching his and we both won the
rest of our games but it meant that i
was half a point i had like the feeling
when i realized that i was gonna win
um that was just
so amazing it was like the first time
that i was the best at my age
and at that point
you're hooked yeah at that point i
realized you know
this i could actually be very good at
this so you you kind of saw
where did you think your ceiling would
be did you see that
did you see that one day you could be
the number one no i didn't i didn't
think that was possible at all um
but when'd you first i thought i could
be the best in norway
the best in norway at that point one day
because like i started relatively late
right
and also like
i knew that i studied a lot more than
the others i knew that i had a passion
that they didn't have they saw
chess as something like
it was you know it was a hobby it was
like an activity it was like
um
it was like going to to football
practice or
any other sports like you go you
practice like once or twice a week and
then you play a tournament at the
weekend that's that's what you did for
me it wasn't like that like i would
go with my books and my board every day
after school
and i wouldn't i would just constantly
be trying to learn new things i had like
two hours of
internet time on the computer each week
and i would always spend them on on jazz
like
i think
before i was
13 or 14 i'd never opened
a
browser for any other reason than to
play chess
would you describe that as love or as
obsession or something in between
it's everything yeah everything
but
so i mean it wasn't hard for me to tell
at that point that i had something that
the other other kids
didn't because i was never the the one
to grasp
something
very very quickly but once i started i
always got hooked and then i never
stopped learning
what would you say you've talked about
the middle game
as a as a place where you can play pure
chess
what do you think is beautiful to you
about chess
like the thing when you were 11.
what is beautiful to me
is when your opponent can predict every
single one of your moves and they still
lose
how does that happen no like it means
that at some point
early you're planning your evaluation
has been better
so that you play just very simply very
clearly it looks like you did nothing
special and your opponent lost without a
chance
so you're how do you think about that
by the way you basically narrow down
this gigantic tree of options
to where your opponent has less and less
and less options
to win to escape and then they're
trapped yeah that's it essentially
is there some aspect to the patterns
themselves to the positions
to the elegance of like
the the dynamics of the game that you
just find beautiful that that doesn't
that
where you forget about the opponent
i general i try and create
harmony on the board like what i would
usually find harmonious is that
the pieces work
together that they protect each other
and that there are no pieces that are
suboptimally placed
or
if they are suboptimally placed
they can be improved pretty easily like
i hate when
i have one piece that i know is badly
placed and i cannot improve it
when yeah when you're thinking about the
the harmony of the pieces when you're
looking at the position you're
evaluating it
are you looking at at the whole board
or is it like a bunch of groupings of
pieces overlapping
and like dancing together kind of thing
i would say it's more of the lighter
that would be more
uh precise that you look
i mean
i look mostly closer to the middle but
then i would focus on one like there are
usually like one grouping of pieces on
one side and then some more closer to
the
the other side so i would
um i would think of it a little bit that
way so and everything is kind of
gravitating to the middle
if it's going well then yes
and in harmony yeah in in harmony or
like if you can control the middle you
can more easily attack on both sides
that applies to
pretty much any game
it's as simple as that and like
attacking on one side without control of
the middle
would
feel
very non-harmonious for for me like i i
talked about the 10th game
and
in the world championship like that's
the time i was the most nervous and it
was
because it was a kind of attack that i
hate where you just have to
you're abandoned one side and you
the attack has to work
there was one side and part of the
middle as well which i didn't control at
all and that that's
like the opposite of harmony for me
what advice would you give to
chess players of
different levels how to improve in chess
very beginner complete beginner
i mean at every level is there is there
something you can
it's very very hard for me to say
because
i mean
the easiest way is like love chess be
obsessed well that's a really important
statement but that doesn't work for
everybody so i feel like it can feel
like a grind so you're saying if the
less can feel like a grind the better
the better yeah at least for you
that's for sure but i'm also very very
skeptical about giving advice because i
think
again my way only works if you
have some
combination of talented and obsession so
i'm not sure that i'd generally
recommend it like what i've done
doesn't go with
what most coaches suggest for their kids
i've been lucky that i've had coaches
from from early on that have been very
very hands-off and just allowed me to do
my thing basically
well there's a lot to be said about
uh cultivating the obsession
like really yeah really letting that
flourish
to where you spend a lot of hours
like with the chessboard in your head
and it doesn't feel like a struggle no
so like
just letting me do my thing like if you
give me a bunch of work it will probably
feel like a shore and if you don't give
me i will spend
all of that time on my own without
thinking that it's it's work or without
thought that i'm doing this to improve
my chess
well in terms of learning stuff like
books there's
one thing that's relatively novel
from your perspective people are
starting now is there's youtube there's
a lot of good youtubers
you're a part-time youtuber you have
stuff on youtube i guess
yeah uh but do you like any particular
youtubers um
i could just recommend like stuff i've
seen so a good matter the gotham chess
cortez live
um i really like uh st louis chess club
uh danielle naraditsky and uh john
bartholomew those are good channels but
is there something you can recommend no
all of them are good
you know the best recommendation i
could
give as a godmother um
purely how much did he pay you to say
that no so the thing about that
is that i haven't really i have so i can
tell you i've never watched any of his
videos from from start to finish yeah
i'm not like i'm not the target audience
obviously
but
i think the only chess
youtube video that my dad has ever
watched from start to finish
is agamatur and
he said like i watched one of his videos
i wanted to know what what it was all
about
because i think aguamata is like
the same strength as my father or maybe
just a little bit weaker like
1900 or something my father is probably
about 2 000.
and my father has played chess his whole
life uh he loves he absolutely loves the
game it was like that's the only
time he's actually sat through one of
those videos and he said like yeah i get
it i enjoy it so that's the best
recommendation i i could give that's
the only channel that my father actually
enjoys this is hilarious i talked i
talked to him before this to ask him if
he has any questions for you and uh he
said no just just do your thing you know
what no he's so careful he wouldn't uh
do that he did mention jokingly about
uh evan's gambit i think is that a thing
evan's gambit is some weird thing he
made up it might be an inside joke i
don't i don't know but he asked me to
well anyway yeah i didn't even get um
it's something that you
didn't even realize that he placed the
evan's camera like he plays a lot of
gambits that are wait evans gambit is a
thing yeah yeah that's the thing like
that's an old opening from the 1800s uh
captain evans apparently invented it why
would he mention that particular one
yeah something hilarious about that one
i don't know i i don't think i've ever
faced the evan's gambit and uh
in the game i feel like both of you are
trolling and trolling me right now
but i mean
he's played a lot of other gambits
maybe this is the one he wanted to to
mention so this maybe this is called the
evans gambit as well
but i just know it as like the two two
g4 gambit maybe this is the one like
this one he has
this one he has played a bunch
uh
and he he he's been telling me a lot
about his games in this line he's like
oh it's not so bad
and i'm like yeah but you're upon down
yeah but i can i can sort of see it i
can sort of um i can sort of understand
it and he's like
he's proud of the fact that nobody like
told him to play this line or anything
he came up with it
himself and there's this
uh i'll tell you another story about my
father so there's this line that i call
that i called the henry carlson line
um so at some point
you know he never knew a lot of openings
in in chess but i taught him
i taught him a couple of openings as
black
it's the
uh it's the specialty of sicilian that
i've played a lot myself also
during the um the world championship in
2018 i won a bunch of games in 2019 as
well so that's one opening and i also
taught him as black to play the ragosan
defense
um and then so the regular defense goes
like goes like this
it's characterized by
um by this bishop move
um and so
he would play those openings pretty
pretty exclusively and as black and the
tournaments that he did play and also
the svechnikov sicilian is like that's
the only
two of my sisters play
have played a bunch of chess tournaments
as well and that's the only
opening they know as well so my my
family's reporter is very narrow so
so this is this this is the system black
goes here and then we are from white
takes the pawn and black takes the pawn
so at some point i was watching one of
my
my father's
online blitz game
this game and as white he played this
this
so this is called the car con defense he
took the pawn
it was taken back then he went with the
knights
um his opponent went here and then he
played the bishop here
so i
i'd never seen this opening before and i
was like
wow
how on earth did he come up with that
and he said no i just played the ragosa
with the different colors because if the
knight was here it would be the same
position i was like i never
i was like
how am i
like one of the best
20 players in the world and i've never
thought about that so i actually started
playing
i started playing this line uh as white
with pretty decent results and it
results in it actually became
kind of popular and everybody
who asked about the line it's like i
would always tell them yeah that's the
henry carlson navigation
i wouldn't necessarily explain why it
was called that i would just always call
it that so i really hope at this point
at some point
this line will be uh we'll find it its
rightful name
and uh yeah it finds its ways into the
history books can you uh what what what
did you learn about life from your dad
what what role has your dad play in your
life
he's taught me a lot of things but most
of all
as long as you win a chess then
everything else is fine
[Laughter]
um i think
my
especially my father but my parents in
general they they always wanted me to
get a good education
and um
find a job and so on um even though my
father loves chest and he wanted me to
to play chess i don't think
he had
any plans for me to be professional i
think things changed at some point like
i was less and less interested in school
and
for a long time we were kind of going
back and forth fighting about that um
especially my father but also my mother
a little bit
it was at times a little bit difficult
they wanted you to go to school yeah
they sort of wanted me to
do more school to have more options and
then
i i think at some point
they just gave up
but i think that sort of coincided when
i was actually starting to make real
money off tournaments and after that you
know everything's been
sort of easy and like in terms of the
family like
they've never
put any pressure on me or they've never
put any demands on me um they're just
yeah miners has to focus on chess that's
that that's um that's it like i think
they taught me in general to be
curious about the world and to get
a
decent general education not necessarily
from from school but like just knowing
um about the world around you and
knowing history and being you know just
being interested in society i think
in that sense they've done well
and he's been with you throughout your
chess career i mean there's something to
be said
about just
family support and love that you have
that you know this world is a lonely
place
it's good to have people around you
there like
yeah um
they've got your back kind of you know
yeah uh
it's a cliche but i think to some extent
all the people you surround yourself
with
they can help you a lot
it's only family that only has their own
interests at heart
and so
for that reason like my father is like
the only one that's been like constantly
in the team that and that he's always
been around and it's it's for that
reason that i know he has my back no
matter what
now there's a cliche question here
but let's try to actually get
to some deep truth perhaps
but people who don't know much about
chess seem to like to use chess as a
metaphor for everything in life
but there is some aspect to the decision
making
to the kind of reasoning and involved in
chess that's transferable to other
things
can you can you speak to that in your in
your own life and in general
the kind of reasoning involved with
chess how much is that this transfer to
life out there it just helps to make
decisions i mean of all of all kinds
yeah that would be my main takeaway that
you learned to make informed guesses in
a limited amount of time
i mean does it frustrate you when you
know that you have
geopolitical thinkers and leaders you
know henry kissinger will often talk
about
geopolitics as a game of chess or 3d
chess
is that a too oversimplified of a
projection or
or do you think that the kind of
deliberations you have on the world
stage is
is similar to the kind of decision
making you have on the chessboard
well i never i'm never trying to get
reelected when i play a game of chess
there's no special interest you have to
get happy yeah that kind of no that kind
of helps no i can i can understand
that obviously for every action there's
a reaction and you have to to calculate
far ahead it probably would be a good
thing if more
big players on the international scene
thought a little bit more like
like a chess player in that sense like
trying to make
a good decision based on
based on limited amount of data rather
than
thinking about other
other factors but it's so tough uh but
it does annoy me when
when people make moves that they know
are wrong for different reasons and they
should know if they did some calculation
they should know they're wrong yeah
exactly that they should know that are
wrong and
so much
politics is like
it's um
you're you're often asked to do
something when you're
when it would be much better to do
nothing uh
like
no but that happens in chess all the
time like you have you have a choice
like i often tell people that
in certain situations you should not try
and win you should just let your
opponent lose loose
and
that happens in politics all the time
yeah just let your opponents
continue whatever
they're doing and then you'll win don't
try to do something just to do something
often
they say in chess that
having a bad plan is better than having
no plan it's absolute nonsense
i forget what general said it but
it was like
don't interrupt your enemy when they're
making a mistake
yeah i think
also um
patron um the the former world champion
said um
when your opponent wants to play the
dutch defense don't stop them
i mean chess players will know that it's
the same thing
actually this reminds me
is there something you found really
impressive about queen's gambit the tv
show you know that's one of the things
that really captivated the public
imagination about chess people don't
play chess or became very curious about
the game about the beauty of the game
the drama of the game all that kind of
stuff is there in terms of accuracy in
terms of the actual games played that
you found
impressive
first of all they did the chess that did
the chess while they did it accurately
and also
they found actual games and positions
that i never never seen before
which really captivated me like i would
i would not follow the um
the story at times i was just trying to
wow where the hell did i find that game
trying to solve the positions
so beth harmon the uh the the main
character
were you impressed by the play she was
doing in in the like was there a
particular style that they developed
consistently but she was just at the end
she was just totally universal like at
the start
she was probably a bit too too
aggressive but no she was absolutely
universal you know wait what what were
the what adjective are you using
universal in the sense that she could
play in any any style
oh interesting and and was dominant in
that way so wow they said there was a
development in style too throughout the
show yeah for sure it's really
interesting they did they did that yeah
and uh it actually happened with me a
bit as well like i started out really
aggressive
then i became probably
too technical at some point
taking a little bit too few risks i'm
not playing dynamic enough and then i
started to get a little bit better at
dynamics so that now i'm
i would say definitely the most
universal player in terms of um in terms
of style
are there any skills in chess that are
transferable to poker
so as you're playing around with poker a
little bit now
how fundamentally different of a game is
it
what i find the most transferable
probably is not like letting
past decisions
dictate
future thinking yeah
but in terms of the patterns in the
betting strategies and all that kind of
stuff uh what about bluffing do you
because i've left way too much
it does seem you enjoy bluffing and uh
daniel negrano was saying yeah you're
not quite good at it
uh but yeah it has very little material
to go by sample size is small yeah
no i mean i enjoy bluffing for um the
more the gambling aspects the the thrill
of
so not the technical aspect of the
bluffing like you would on the
chessboard not bluffing in the same
sense but there is some element um
but i do enjoy it on on the chessboard
like if i um know that like oh i
successfully scared away my opponent for
making the best move that's of course
satisfying
in that same way it might be satisfying
in poker right that you represent
something you scare away your opponent
yeah the same kind of like yeah and also
like you tell a story
you try and tell a story and then
they believe it yeah tell tell a story
with your betting with your
um
all the different other cues yeah do you
like the money aspect the the betting
strategies
so it's like it's like it's almost like
another layer on top of it right like
it's it's the uncertainty
in the cards
but the betting there's so much freedom
to the betting
i'm not very good at that so
i cannot say that i understand it
completely
you know
when it comes to
different sizing and
well and all that i just haven't studied
it enough how much of luck is part of
poker would you say from what what
you've seen
versus skill i mean it's so different in
the sense that you can be
one of the best players in the world and
lose two or three years in a row without
that being
being like a massive outlier
okay the the the thing that more than
one person told me
that you're very good at is trash
talking
i don't think i am
a lot of people who
make
those observations about me i think they
just expect very very little so they
expect
from the best chess player in the world
yeah they just
anything that's non-robotic is
interesting
also when it comes to trash talking like
i have the biggest advantage in the
world that i'm the best of what i'm
doing so trash talking becomes very very
very easy because i can back it up yeah
yeah but a lot of people that are
extremely good at stuff don't trash talk
and they're not good at it i don't think
i'm very good at it it's just that i can
back it up which makes it seem that i'm
i'm better and also you're even doing it
now
also being non-robotic or not completely
robotic yeah
yeah i'm you're not trash talking you're
just stating facts that's right
have you ever have you ever considered
that uh
there will be trash talking and over the
chessboard and some of the big
tournaments
like adding that kind of component or
even talking you know
um that would that completely distract
from the gamer chess no i think it could
be um funny and
when people play off fan games when they
play blitz games like people trash talk
all the time it's a normal part of the
game
so you uh you emphasize fun a lot
uh do you think we're living inside of a
simulation
that is trying to maximize fun
but that's only happened for the last
you know 100 years or so no that's
like the fun has always been increasing
i think yeah okay it's always been
increasing but i feel like it's been
increasing
exponentially yeah
i mean the or at least the importance of
fun
but i guess it depends on the society as
well like in the west we've had such
uh christian
influence and
i mean christianity hasn't
exactly embraced the concept of fun over
over time so well actually to push back
i think forbidding certain things kind
of makes them more fun
so sometimes i think you need to
say you're not allowed to do this
and then a lot of people start doing it
and then they have fun doing that
because it's like uh
um
it's doing a thing in the face of the
resistance of the thing so whenever
there's resistance that does somehow
make it more fun
oppressive regimes has always kind of
been
been kind of good for comedy no
like
i heard yes supposedly like in the
soviet union i don't know about fun but
supposedly comedy like at least
underground it's it's right yeah there's
a well no it permeates the entire
culture there's a dark humor yeah that
uh sort of the cruelty the absurdity of
life really
really brings out the humor amongst the
populists plus vodka on top of that but
this idea that
for example elon musk has that
um
the most entertaining outcome was the
most likely
that it seems like the most absurd silly
funny thing seems to be the thing so it
happens more often than um than it
should and it's something that goes
viral in our modern connected world
and so the fun stuff the memes
spread and then we start to optimize for
the for the fun meme
that seems to be a fundamental property
of of the reality we live in
and so emerges the met the fun maximizer
in all walks of life
like
in chess
in in in poker and everything
i think you're you're skeptical no i'm
not skeptical uh i'm just
i'm just taking it all in
uh but i i find it interesting and not
at all impossible
do you ever get lonely
oh yeah for sure
um like a chess player's life is by
definition pretty lonely
um
because you have nobody else to blame
but yourself when you lose or you don't
achieve the results that you want to
achieve
it's difficult for you to find
comfort elsewhere it's it's in your own
mind yeah it's you versus yourself
really yeah really
but it's uh
you know it's um it's part of the
profession but i think
any
like sport or activity where it's
where it's just you
and your own mind is just by definition
only are you worried that it destroys
you
oh not at all as long as i'm aware of it
then it's fine and uh
i don't think
the inherent loneliness of my profession
really
affects the rest of my life in in a
major way
what uh role does love play in the human
condition
in your lonely life
of
calculation you know i'm like everybody
else uh
trying uh
you know
trying to find love no not necessarily
like trying to find love sometimes i am
sometimes i'm
i'm not i'm just trying to find my way
yeah and
my
love for
for the game
obviously it comes and goes a little bit
but there's like there's always at least
some level of love so that doesn't
doesn't go away but i think in other
parts of life i think it's just
about
doing things that make you happy
that give you joy that that also makes
you
more receptive to to love in general so
that that has been my approach to
to love now for quite a while that
i'm just trying to live my best life
and then
the love will um
will come uh when it when it comes and
in
in terms of romantic love it has come
and gone in my life it's not there now
uh but i'm not worried about
that
i'm more worried about you know not
worried but more like trying to just
be a good version of um of myself i
cannot always be the best version of
myself but at least try to be good
yeah and keep your heart open what is
this uh danielle johnston song true love
will find you in the end
no it may or may not but but he will
only find you
if uh
oh [ __ ] how does it go if you're looking
so like you have to be open to it yeah
it may or may not yeah yeah and no
matter what you're going to lose it in
the end because it all ends the whole
thing ends yeah yeah so
i i don't think
stressing over that like
obviously
it's so human that you can't help it to
some degree
but i feel like stressing over love
that's the blueprint for
rather whether you're looking or
you're not looking or
you're in a relationship or marriage or
anything like stressing over it is like
the blue blue print for being unhappy
uh just to clarify confusion i have um
just a quick question how does the night
move
so the knight moves in an l
um and uh unlike in shogi you can move
both forwards and backwards
it is
quite a
nimble piece it can jump over everything
but it's less happy in open position
where it has to move from from side to
side
quickly
i am generally more of a bishops guy
myself for the old debate i just
prefer quality over the intangibles but
uh i can appreciate a good night once in
a while
last simple
question what's the meaning of life
magnus carlsen
there is obviously no meaning to life is
that obvious
i think we're here by accident there's
no meaning it ends at some point yeah
but it's still a great thing so
yeah
you can still have fun even if there's
no me yeah you can still have fun you
can try and pursue your your goals
whatever they may be but i'm pretty sure
there's no special meaning and
trying to
to find it also doesn't make a whole lot
of sense to me
for me like life is both meaningless and
meaningful for just being here trying to
to make not necessarily the most of it
but the things that make you
make you happy both short term and also
long term
yeah it seems to be full of cool stuff
to enjoy
it certainly does
and uh one of those is having a
conversation with you uh magnus it's a
huge honor to talk to you thank you so
much for spending this time with me
i can't wait to see what you do in this
world and thank you for creating so much
elegance and beauty on the chessboard
and beyond so thanks for talking today
brother thank you so much thanks for uh
having me uh and uh
i wanted to say this at the start but i
never get really got the chance i was
always a bit apprehensive about
doing this podcast because you are a
very smart guy and your audience is
very smart
and
i always had
a bit of imposter syndrome so i'll tell
you this now after
the podcast so please do do judge me but
i i hope you've enjoyed it i loved it
you're a brilliant man and it's it's i
love the fact they have imposter
syndrome because a lot of us do and so
that that's beautiful to see even at the
very top do you still feel like an
imposter
ah thank you brother thanks for talking
today
thanks for listening to this
conversation with magnus carlson to
support this podcast please check out
our sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from bobby fisher
chess is a war over the board
the object is to crush the opponent's
mind
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time